Speaker 1: So this next story is just incredible.
You know, you have an investigation going on into
whether the Trump Organization has been
submitting filing false financial statements.
We have the allegation from Michael
Cohen and others that Donald Trump's
organization would regularly overstate or
understate the value of real estate assets,
depending on whether it was more convenient
for the value to be lower or higher.
You have an investigation being done by the
New York Attorney General Letitia James looking
into this. You have all these different things.
Yesterday, we told you about Trump's accounting
firm saying we're no longer working with them
and you can't trust the financial statements
from the last ten years. And even though they
continue to claim they've done nothing wrong,
Trump then just sends out one of these
statements admitting to the entire thing,
admitting that indeed, the financial statements
cannot be trusted. It's it's beyond belief,
he says. It's a witch hunt. Investigators have to
go through all of these loopholes and documents
just to figure out what's going on. The
investigation's been going on for some time.
And then Trump just comes out and admits the
entire thing. Yesterday, a statement was put out
by Liz Harrington. Donald Trump sort of like new
ish spokeswoman, and it says refuting the latest
claims from Trump's now former accounting firm.
We have a great company with fantastic assets that
are unique, extremely valuable, valuable and in
many cases, far more valuable than what was listed
in our financial statements. He's admitting it.
He's saying we listed one value in the financial
statements, but the real value is different. Now
he's saying it in this way to try to suggest it's
no big deal, but understand that he's admitting
that the allegation is true. The allegation is
the real value, and the listed value are not
the same. And you know it. And he's admitting
the listed value and the value we believe to be
the real value are not the same. And we know that,
and we believe that to be true. He's admitting
to the entire thing. He also says my company
has among the best real estate and
other assets anywhere in the world,
has significant amounts of cash and has relatively
very little debt, which is totally current,
which again, talking about your debt in this
way. If you're Trump, suggests he's probably
lying about that too. But he's admitting it.
He's admitting it. And this this actually
makes it worse if Trump tries to file
bankruptcy. Remember that Donald Trump,
when confronted about his business bankruptcies,
are said, Well, I know the system. Those are
not personal bankruptcies. Those are business
bankruptcies, and they're done strategically.
If you deliberately list incorrect values for your
assets and then you file Chapter 11 bankruptcy,
the creditors who are entitled to assets, if you
were to file such a bankruptcy, you were admitting
that they relied on false statements
from you when they became your creditors.
You gave them incorrect information. And so it
actually makes any potential bankruptcy filings in
the future. And of course, makes us wonder about
the bankruptcy filings in the past, the false
basis for that as well. It's actually incredible
now. And as if this wasn't enough. Donald Trump,
then in the statement, also admits that the
allegation against his CFO, Allen Weisselberg,
that he received fringe benefits and didn't pay
taxes on them is also true. I mean, he's admitting
to the entire thing. Trump also said the charge
against a 74 year old long term wonderful employee
is he didn't pay taxes on a company car or a
company apartment. Do others pay such a tax?
Did Cy Vance pay a tax on his car and a charge
having to do with my paying for the education of
his grandchildren? He's admitting it. Guys
understand that the way these benefits are
supposed to work. I know this because I have a
company vehicle leased through my business, but
I have to pay tax on that. Imagine that you have
a company car and the lease is five grand a year.
That five grand. You don't pay. The business pays,
but it's considered a fringe benefit, meaning you
should be paying taxes on the five grand as an
employee. And Trump doesn't deny it. He just says
other people are also breaking the law by not
paying that tax. It's it's the investigation is
not necessary because he's admitting to
everything. Every statement he puts out seems
to be a confession of some kind, and it's truly
incredible. But it shouldn't come as a big shock.